hier je vous ai présenté le nouveau aux
moines plus 6t vous est présentée il ya
très longtemps le one + 6 et je vous ai
fait donc hier une vidéo de test
une autre vidéo de boxing j'espère vous
les avez regardés que vous avez fait
comme ça il ya peu plus précis sur ce
smartphone est aujourd'hui je voulais
faire une autre vidéo qui me paraissent
être essentiel c'est la différence entre
le one piece 6
le one + 6 t voir vraiment les gros
points de différence qu'elles sont un
peu du coup les nouveautés est ce qu'on
peut rester sur le wan +6
est ce qu'il faut aller sur le web plus
ce système je vais vous aider un petit
peu à dégrossir ça et au final ça sera à
vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire quel est votre choix si vous
l'avez tout ça tout ça
allez on y va
[Musique]
dans la famille web plus je voudrais le
comte +6 sorti il ya quelques mois et
maintenant le one piece liste et qui est
annoncée il ya pa très très très
longtemps
on a donc deux modèles de 2018 très sexy
très beau mais qui marque par contre
chacun leurs différences et la première
on le voit elle se situe tout en haut
c'est l'encoche parce qu'il faut quand
même savoir que les opus 6 est un peu
plus petit clou one + 6 t lorraine +6 va
mesurer 155,7 74,4 et une épaisseur de
7,75
mm tout ça pour un poids de 170 5
grammes tandis que le one piece système
est un peu plus long mesure 157,5 au
lieu de 155,7 autant dire que ça se
tient à pas grand chose
[Musique]
74,8 là il est un peu plus petit que le
modèle et il a un petit peu plus et pelé
il fait 8,2 mm et légèrement plus long
de quelques grammes il fait 4 185
grammes contre 177 g franchement j'ai
tient comme ça je ne sens pas la
différence de l'autre côté à quelques
grammes c'est plutôt normal au niveau de
la taille de l'écran on a par contre une
différence sur le web plus s'ils sont à
l'écran de 6,28 pouces tandis que sur
les 28 6 t on à l'écran de 6,41 pouces
je suis pas sûr qu'à première vue ça
vous saute aux yeux mais pourtant une
différence
la différence est très très très légère
vous la voyez en regardant en bas vous
avez un menton qui est légèrement plus
grand sur le wan +6 6,6 par rapport aux
assistés et une très légère différence
sur le haut le one plus cité est un peu
plus loin l'écran va un peu plus haut
mais sinon fondamentalement ça va comme
ça bon ça doit pas forcément en terme de
résolution là aussi une différence sur
ces mois d'une résolution qui est plus
élevé sur le wan puis 6t forcément
écrans plus grands oblige 2340 par 1080
contre 2280 parmi 80 bon ça change pas
grand chose là où vous avez une
différence sur le ratio là vous avez un
écran 19 9e tandis que sandrine pucistes
et vous êtes un écran 19 points 5/9 ce
sont des points de détail mais il existe
peut-être moins de plus ce système vous
êtes un corning gorilla glass 6 tandis
que song +6 vous avez un corning gorilla
glass 5 tous les en préambule
la grande différence au niveau de
l'encoche sur le voile +6 vous avez
votre caméra qui est là
plus votre haut-parleurs qui se situe
juste là tandis que sur une piste et
vous avez votre caméra qui est là quel
haut parleurs qui est caché juste là là
là très léger pas si vous voyez qu'il
est juste en dessous de mon ongle donc
extrêmement bien camouflés et ça c'est
vraiment bien fait et rien que pour la
différence au niveau de l'encoche
mcluhan fussistes est une vraie belle
grande évolution par rapport aux 26
autres différences et pas des moindres
c'est le capteur d'empreintes digitales
sur le web + 6 vous avez votre capteur
d'empreintes digitales à l'arrière comme
sur les smartphones je dirais qu'on
retrouve beaucoup en 2018 vous prenez
votre smartphone vous posez votre bois
après sa déroute vous êtes content
tandis que 120 consisté à l'arrière
qu'il n'y a absolument pas de capteur le
logo contraire a été un peu remonté ce
qui ne gâche absolument pas le plaisir
par contre le capteur d'empreintes
digitales se positionne sous l'écran
lorsque vous l'allumez il est là il
suffit de positionner votre doigt dessus
il dit les rouilles directement en
termes de rapidité les deux vagues que
ce soit le capteur d'empreintes
digitales dans l'écran ou alors celui
directement à l'arrière du monde + 6
pour voir les démarches très bien
l'autre différence se fait au niveau de
la batterie sur le web + 6 vous avez
batterie de trois mille trois cent
millions père heures de leur recharge
rapide bon ce point de vue là ça change
pas test sur le moins de puce system ews
avait deux batteries qui était sûr
booster 3700 milliards terreur 400
millions terreur de plus l'autonomie
était déjà excellentes 126 elle
carrément démentiel 128,6 tessa c'est
aussi vraiment un excellent point il ya
aussi une différence au niveau du
stockage de base 126 vous aviez trois
versions 64 giga 128 giga 250 gigas sur
le web peut citer la version 64 giga a
tout simplement disparu dont vous avez
une version de base en 128 giga et 256
giga entre différentes cette fois ci et
logiciel vous avez sur le web + 6 t
le smart boost qui vous permet de lancer
vos applications beaucoup plus
rapidement
ça vous n'avez pas sur le wan +6 les
appareils photo sont exactement les
mêmes que ce soit le double capteur à
l'arrière
ou alors le simple capteur à l'avant
c'est vraiment exactement la même chose
même capteur mêmes lentilles même
ouverture c'est tout pareil et pourtant
et pourtant il ya une vraie différence
une vraie optimisation logiciel qui
était fait sur le wan +6 tes meilleures
photos nuit meilleur portrait meilleur
cette fille je vous invite à vous
abonner à rester connectés parce que
d'ici quelques jours
ça vous sortir ma vidéo de test photo
vidéo justement comme ça vous pourrez le
voir
dire est ce que vous en pensez autre
différence et pas des moindres howell
plus a fait le choix de supprimer sa
prise jack don d'organe peut citer vous
n'avez pas du tout deux prises jack vous
n'avez pas pour autant de hauts parleurs
stéréos toujours un haut parleur mono
mais cette fois ci il n'y a plus de
prise jack
il faudra donc vous contenter d'un
adaptateur usb type sévère prise jack
insérer directement dans votre système
sinon d'un point de vue design ça reste
inchangée vous avez ici votre bouton de
volume
votre tiroir de cartes sim qui reste là
toujours double carte sim toujours de
l'usb c'est pour ça je vous le dis le
prise jack qui a dégagé votre bouton
pour l'allumer ici votre slide mi-août
vibrations sont est au dessus c'est
sensiblement la même chose
le design à l'arrière est quasiment
aussi inchangé mise à part a
effectivement comme je vous disais tout
à l'heure
le capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
allait gagner vous avez toujours votre
flash les deux là on a donc deux
smartphones de 2018 qui sont vraiment
beaux vraiment bien aboutie et surtout
des performances qui sont complètement
hallucinante
alors ça soit parce que d'un point de
vue purement technique on a exactement
les mêmes spec snapdragon 845 si j'ai
bien drame ou 8 gigas de ram et pourtant
à configuration équivalente le howe a de
plus ce système est plus rapide que le
web le 6 alors le one + 6 est déjà très
rapide jusqu'à présent et est classé
dans le top 3 des smartphones les plus
rapides vous avez le rock funk d'asus
vous avez le black shark de chimie et
vous avez ensuite le moins de +6 le one
+ 6 t elle faire sauter du top 3 et va
se classer à la deuxième position en
tout cas c'est ce que j'ai pu voir lors
de mon test sur un toutou d'ailleurs si
vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo de test je
vous invite à aller la voir vous allez
voir c'est vraiment une belle bête
voilà donc pour cette différence
significative
venez par la ve départ à la on vient là
on montre un peu la tête tout va bien
vous verrez donc pour cette différence
significative entre le one + 6 t et le
wall +6 à vous de me dire maintenant ce
que vous en pensez alors là j'ai des
versions j'ai le mirror blague j'ai le
midnight black on peut trouver les mêmes
finitions dans les deux modèles qui sont
là depuis absolument pas de différence
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
comment vous le trouvez sur une puce
system est ce que vous pensez que
vraiment il met une claque au moins de
+6 est-ce que vous pensez que au
contraire le wall pucistes reste
vraiment très très très bon hyper
concurrentiel par rapport au monde
puisse s'y steckel encoches vous
préférez entre ces deux modèles la
grande roche dure depuis 6 ou la toute
petite encoche du votre +6 tessa créé
malgré tout une différence du point de
vue design
lorsqu'on les regarde même site les
écrans sont sensiblement de la même
dimension 6,28 6,41 bon mais
malgré tout il ya bien une vraie
différence et en terme d'expérience
lorsque vous regardez des vidéos
croyez-moi ça compte dix membres
tout ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire vous invite à rester
connectés parce que d'ici quelques jours
je vais publier mon test photo vidéo du
wan plus ce système
à venir également les tests du mail vin
et du match d'impro de huawei a aussi
parlé des google pixels 3 google pixels
3xl on va parler de plein d'autres
smartphones de samsung pas commis on va
parler d'apple qui vous sortir aussi mon
test de l'iphone 10 air d'apple il ya
plein de choses à dire une grosse actu
une fin d'année assez incroyable et
aussi des ordinateurs qui vont arriver
enfin bref je n'en dis pas plus que
sinon on va y passer la soirée thrill
mort qui est aux guéré voilà merci à
vous soyez sages et à très bientôt
je vous embrasse
[Musique]
où